over the years you've been involved the
access to mobile phones access to other
forms of technological innovation have
really boosted women's ability to
participate in this sort of economic
financial sector where do you see again
the further gain the most game can be
made whether it's through mobile devices
mobile banking and how important is this
you're really driving up women's of
power empowerment in the developing
world yeah so I think mobile phones are
going to be one of the very key things
it's kind of a route around the banking
system in a sense because if you think
about it the poor are not welcomed at
banks and even if they put their money
in their pocket they'll tell you if they
get on the train or the bus they have to
spend the money to get on the train of
the best they got to travel to the city
they get robbed on the way and then they
get to the bank and they're not welcome
and yet mobile phones are all over the
developing world I'll be in a remote
dusty village where you wouldn't think
there was a mobile phone that could ring
around and I'll be talking to a woman
and chickens will be running around and
all of a sudden the phone rings in her
pocket I didn't know she had one and
she'll pull it out and somebody's
calling her and so what we're finding is
that when men and women have access and
particularly women to mobile banking on
their phone where they can save a dollar
a day $2 day because women do have
income as much as we don't survey them
and find out you when you talk to them
and we're starting to now survey them
they have lots of income and so when
they have a be not not a lot personally
but they'll have little bits of it at
times when they can start to save it in
a bank account and it's not in a tin can
under their bed where a relative can
come ask them for it or it doesn't get
eaten by rats when it's in a Mobile
Money account then when it comes time
for the school fees she's got money to
put her kid in school and when it comes
time where there's a drought which
happens a lot in Africa or food shortage
she's got money to go buy food at the
market and it's transformative in these
women's lives and we actually there's a
recent survey that came out a very
long-term study about women who've had
access to mobile banking over the last
three years and it's listed a
substantial number of women out of
poverty in Kenya and Kenya is one of the
places haven't had mobile banking the
longest so I'm very optimistic about
this
just have to make sure that mobile
phones and those bank accounts really
get in all women's hands not just a
subset of women's hands